[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein schwedisches rezept
ich werde köttbullar machen
ich glaube manche sagen einfach ikea
köttbullar dazu aber im schwedischen ist
es so wenn ein als nach dem krieg steht
dann spricht man es aus so hab ich
zumindest gelesen original weiß es nicht
ich war nämlich noch nie in schweden
beim ikea okay da waren wir schon ein
paar mal aber ich muss auch sagen dass
ich dort die schwedischen stadt pula
noch nie gegessen habe aber ich kann mir
ungefähr forscherin wie sie schmecken
ich habe so ein paar rezepte
durchgelesen und habe jetzt so für mich
mein rezept für euch zusammengefasst und
weil das häuschen durch zu bereiten das
sind hackbällchen in einer leckeren
saucen und ich mache später dazu ein
bisschen kartoffelpüree also richtig
lecker die kinder lieben es und ich
glaube ihr werdet auch für die
hackfleischbällchen verwende ich
butterschmalz vier zwiebel 2
knoblauchzehen zweier etwas paniermehl
senf salz und pfeffer zu würzen
eine festkochende kartoffel und die habe
ich rindfleisch und natürlich petersilie
die zwiebeln und knoblauch 10 habe ich
jetzt bereits geschält und die schneide
ich jetzt eigentlich in feine würfel und
in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal
das butterschmalz in einer großen topf
oder eine pfanne und einfach schon mal
erwärmen
denn die zählen und knoblauchzehen die
werden jetzt angebraten damit man
einfach schön die röstaromen hat
[Musik]
es kommen die zwiebel und knoblauch
würfel hier rein werden dann einfach bei
mittlerer hitze ein bisschen gedünstet
oder angebraten damit sie einfach schön
den geschmack gekommen und ich kann
jetzt schon mal das fleisch vorbereiten
und dann gesagt fleisch hackfleisch tras
machen
ich wollte etwas sagen fleischwolf draus
machen aber nein ich noch hackfleisch
mit dem fleischwolf und hier einfach ab
und zu hören
beim fleisch nehme ich einfach immer
gern rinder nacken und ich mache immer
hackfleisch gern selber weil ich dann
eben auch selbst bestimmen kann welche
fleischsorte ich benutze wie vielfältig
mit drin habe und ich weiß einfach auch
immer dass die qualität stimmt
ich schneide jetzt hier einfach lange
streifen ist nämlich dann besser für den
fleischwolf also keine kleinen würfel
sondern wirklich schöne lange streifen
dann kann nämlich die spirale im
fleischwolf das fleisch in eben unser
kleinert sondern wirklich richtig toll
[Musik]
jetzt einfach hier oben in den
fleischwolf geben und zerkleinern
es geht auch ganz ohne druck dadurch
dass jetzt diese langen stück gehabt
zieht die spirale des fleisch richtig
schönen reiben ab und zu ein bisschen
nachhelfen aber ohne zu drücken
wirklich nur nachschieben
[Musik]
dass das ganze fleisch durch jetzt kann
ich hier auch noch die petersilie rhein
geben
das ist ja ein alles zerkleinerer oder
einfach die petersilie hacken wenn ihr
habt vielleicht schon verkauft dann
kommt hier noch die kartoffel reihen die
halbiert aber dass er durch die öffnung
passt ich werde sie
[Musik]
ich kann ich hier alle restlichen
zutaten dazugeben
also die eier dann die gerösteten
zwiebeln und den topf den was jetzt gar
nicht aus da mache ich später die soße
drin dann hab ich schon mal die zähne
röstaromen so jetzt hier noch paniermehl
und es kann auch sein dass wir ein
bisschen mehr panel benötigen je nachdem
wie groß die eier sind also wenn die
masse zu feucht ist brauchen wir noch
ein bisschen dann salz pfeffer und
selbst viel mehr gewürze gebe ich das
gar nicht dran weil ich ja noch eine
leckere brote mache jetzt einfach schön
alles durchgelesen
konsistenz ist jetzt gut also ich kann
schöne kleine bällchen formen ohne dass
er auseinanderfallen und ich probiere
nicht so gerne rohes hackfleisch
deswegen mache ich es immer gerne so ich
mache einen bildschirm und entweder
kommt kurz in die mikrowelle oder
einfach in die pfanne
man kann nichts anbraten und einfach
probieren ob salz und pfeffer stimmen
also kurz hier rein und die masse werde
ich jetzt aber solange abdecken und so
für etwa eine halbe stunde im
kühlschrank ziehen lassen
dann lassen sie sich nämlich noch besser
kommen
jetzt ist die hackfleisch massa gut
durchgezogen und ich nehme hier einfach
ein blech da habe ich immer ein bisschen
öl drin für die hände und natürlich auch
damit die welt und hier nicht ankleben
und jetzt einfach einen ice portionierer
nehmen die masse portionieren und dann
zu welchen formen und so habe ich schöne
gleichmäßig große welche
ich habe jetzt die bällchen auf zwei
bleche verteilt ihr könnt jetzt entweder
noch mal für eine halbe stunde kühlen
und dann in den topf anbraten oder in
der pfanne
dann bekommen sie richtig tolle
röstaromen ich finde es aber so eine
große menge und es ist auch ein bisschen
einfacher wenn man es einfach im
backofen macht deswegen jetzt zwei
bleche die bildschirm berühren sich
nicht und ich kann jetzt einfach bei
heißluft die bällchen backen und in der
zwischenzeit dann schon mal auf dem herd
die soße ansetzen und kartoffelpüree
ansetzen
[Musik]
für die rahmenlose verwende ich 40 gramm
butter 40 gramm mehl etwa 500 milliliter
rinderbrühe 100 milliliter sahne etwas
zitronensaft salz pfeffer und ein
lorbeerblatt okay des stv das ist alles
also wie gesagt nehme ich jetzt den topf
wenig freund schon hatte mit dem
zwiebelfest aromen
da kommt jetzt die butter rein dass man
eine klassische mehlschwitze das heißt
die botschaft erst mal erwärmen
jetzt kommt ihr das mehl dazu wird
einfach so ein bisschen mit angebrachten
im türkischen sagt man da dazu lenkrad
also bis die farbe sich verändert geht
eben auch dieser markt weg und damit
kriegen wir gleichen richtig leckere
soße
[Musik]
ich finde es eigentlich auch immer ganz
gut wenn man noch gemüse dabei hat also
wir machen jetzt so eine klassische
rahmsauce und ich würde aber auch ganz
lecker wenn man zum beispiel champignons
noch nimmt und mit reingeht
ich möchte sich ja eure soße und euer
essen deswegen alles muss nicht immer
auch regional sein macht einfach alles
noch mit rein was euch schmeckt jetzt
habe ich nur leider keine schwingungen
start von battlefield 3
und wer möchte kann jetzt zum beispiel
ein schuss weißwein dazu geben
das macht die soße einfach ein bisschen
kräftiger ich nehme sie einfach
hinterbrühl
schön rühren wenn ihr wollt dass ich
euch zeigt wie man rinderbrühe macht
dann schreibt einfach in die kommentare
dann mache ich das gerne für euch jetzt
lasse ich es hier vorsichtig aufbauen
willst du noch mit salz und pfeffer
bei mir kommt noch ein schuss
zitronensaft dazu
das war platz ich mach mal ganz
vorsichtig nur salzig schmeckt nicht
gleich noch die brühe jetzt auch gerne
die sahne dazu gießen und dann wirklich
nur bei ganz schwacher hitze leicht
köcheln lassen
ganz ganz ganz nah ist
[Musik]
und wenn ihr möchtet dann können wir zum
beispiel noch körper nehmen aus dem glas
und die soße damit verfeinern also ich
mache dir ganz gerne
die bringen auch einen schönen würzigen
geschmack urteil aber können sie
natürlich auch weglassen erlaubt ist
immer was euch schmeckt mourad massi
auch gerne deswegen nehme ich jetzt
einfach
[Musik]
die soße ist soweit die hackbällchen
sind jetzt auch soweit und ich hatte
hier auch schon kartoffeln aufgesetzt
für kartoffel püree diese jetzt auch
durch die habe ich einfach grob
geschnitten und in wenig wasser gegart
und ich zeige euch mal noch kurz die
zutaten die ich außerdem noch brauche
für das kartoffelpüree brauche ich dann
noch etwas milch butter eine
knoblauchzehe muskat salz und pfeffer
jetzt die kartoffel nehmen und kurz
abgießen
ich lass dir jetzt ganz kurz noch
abtropfen und kann jetzt hier im topf
schon ganz gerne stück butter erwärmen
und da die knoblauchzehe nämlich darin
anbraten die schneide ich jetzt oder
reiben jetzt einfach ganz kurz weiter es
gibt dann auch ein richtig tolles aroma
und von dieser angebratene knoblauchzehe
ich habe jetzt zwei genug herunterziehen
jetzt kann ich nämlich die kartoffel
nehmen und entweder können das jetzt
stampfen oder zum beispiel einfach in
der küchenmaschine zubereiten was ein
absolutes no go ist es echten stabmixer
der macht nämlich kein kartoffelpüree
sondern kann doch viel kleister so dass
ich dich auf die niedrige stufe stellen
die übrige butter noch rein
[Musik]
mit salz pfeffer muskat abschmecken
dann die milch dazu und natürlich auch
den knoblauch
[Musik]
können wir gerne auch in einem kleinen
topf keine frischen top dreckig machen
sagen es muss noch ein kurz berühren und
dann lege ich jetzt gleich schon die hat
menschen in die soße und dann sorgfältig
und hier gebe ich jetzt einfach ein
bisschen soße oder früher rein dass es
hier kurz aufkochen und schützt auch mit
dazu dann habe ich nämlich hier den
bratensatz auch noch niedrig
[Musik]
das riecht lecker und zwar recht zu
schade dass jetzt einfach zu spülen und
weg beschritten hat den alten schwaben
[Musik]
rettig wichtig ist eigentlich nur dass
ihr die hackbällchen einfach kurz vor
dem verzehr in die soße liegt also in
die heiße soße und dann nicht mehr
kochen lassen ansonsten zerfallen sie
nämlich beim kochen und jetzt
kartoffelpüree auf einen teller
wir können aber ich auch andere beilagen
und auch zu nudeln schmeckt ganz gut
ich fand das kartoffelpüree dann in die
mitte so eine kleine mulde
guck mal die kleinen kartoffeln
stückchen ich mag das wenn man da noch
ein bisschen bis hat und traditionell
gibt es dazu tommy du weißt geldpreise
werben denn in schweden ist man die so
dazu du hast ja schonmal original
herrschen alles gut alles gut
okay die auch mit probleme hat rheinberg
wir mal
habt ihr mal ein stückchen deine hände
nicht mal
[Musik]
ich hätte gedacht dass auch ihr passt
echt gut aber ich es trotzdem meine
sachen und gucke dazu ich mag saure
gurke zu hackfleisch weiß nicht ob es
ganz original ist so wie es zubereitet
haben ebenfalls er das so wirklich
lecker probiert das rezept gerne mal aus
also das rezept gibt es auf cds -
blog.de wir denken jetzt ein tisch für
alle es in unser mittagessen und das
wird das nächste mal und schreibt mir
gerne in die kommentare welches rezepte
kennen als nächstes sehen möchte
[Musik]